que mohamed cissé chargé des relations
extérieures du parti de l'espoir pour le
développement national mohamed cissé
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors d'après la cedeao et les
chefs des missions d'observations union
africaine l'élection s'est déroulée de
manière régulière vous partagez cet avis
nous ne partageons pas à l'aller dans la
mesure où c'est une élection illégal
fondée sur la base d' aucune loi
légitime il faut rappeler que la
constitution qui a été imposée au pire
dans l'augmentation à faire plus germans
aujourd'hui cette constitution a été
modifiée dans une vingtaine d'années et
aujourd'hui n'importe quel candidat qui
serait déclarée élue cette élection sera
considéré par nos pour moi un candidat à
la fois illégal et illégitime
alors du coup quand cellou dalein diallo
se déclare vainqueur à l'issue du
premier tour bien que les relient les
résultats ne soient pas officialisé quel
est votre ressenti
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est la
participation d'abord qui est littéraire
de l'infâme nous n'avons pas manqué de
le notifier il compris au niveau de fbf
et laissez nous étions d'accord ensemble
de ne pas prendre part à cette élection
vous ne pouvez pas dire qu'une
constitution est illégal et illégitime
et prendre part à une élection qui sera
organisée sur la base de cette même
constitution
cela revient à reconnaître à la fois la
constitution mais aussi le cadre
d'organisation il faut pas oublier aussi
qu'il y avait beaucoup écrire par
rapport aux conditions d'ordre sont une
élection libre et transparente
donc tout cela motive et notre refus de
prendre part à ce que nous avons appelé
des masters et c'est un parti de
l'opposition a estimé qu'il ne pouvait
gagner
malgré ces conditions des fichiers non
assainies des conditions d'organisation
aussi d'en éclairer contenu de
l'imputation faute de l'année
ration dans le processus électoral et
son parti est aujourd'hui le résultat ne
doit pas étonner ainsi le professeur
alpha condé dit qu'il est ce qui est
clair pour nous cette élection que ce
soir cellou dalein diallo et alpha condé
quelle que soit la personne déclarée
élue nous considérons cela comme un coup
du conditionnel c'est à dire que vous ne
faites pas confiance conclut à la route
rail de la colline de la commission
électorale nationale indépendante
cela est une implication
ce qui permet d'organiser une élection
dans un pays c'est d'abord le cadre
légal
nous n'avons pas de constitution
aujourd'hui en guinée
en termes clairs la constitution qui est
en train d'être appliquée n'a été ni est
votée par le peuple
en tout cas ni aussi sous les procédures
normales de proposition d'une
constitution dont ils ont imposé la
condition ils ont organisé des élections
après le vote des citoyens
une vingtaine d'artistes a été changé
dans cette constitution avant
promulgation
comment voulez vous qu'une élection
organisée sur la base de cette
constitution soit considérée comme une
aide aux élections crédibles et
transparentes
du coup un sauna ou d'états ont pas
gêner d'échanger une vingtaine
d'articles dans une constitution après
le vote qu'est ce qui les empêcherait de
changer d'avis rappel de pv d'aveux ici
déduire de votre trait question des
principes du code dans ce contexte que
vous vous dénoncez vous que votre parti
est ce que vous vous craignez des
tensions fortes dans le pays dans les
prochains jours ou à l'issue des
résultats
la tension est déjà là la tension est là
des violences ont commencé ppt plaisir
ou pas qu'à conakry à tirer pour et
c'était la même chose
alma sens il ya eu des violences à qui
ce trouve aussi a eu des violences en
ahl vous guider dans certaines villes
c'était le cas avant la tenue des
élections
après l'accroc si c'est le cas tant qu
il était mort déjà dense on ne peut pas
dire qu'il n'y a pas de violence là où
les guinéens ont perdu la vie et tout
cela était malheureusement prévisible et
aujourd'hui long
sont plus dans le cadre d'une prévention
de conflits en guinée c'est de voir
maintenant comment on peut prévoir la
situation parce qu'il le conflit est
déjà là il faut trouver un cadre
approprié
s'ils semblent hors de position n'est
pas n'est pas épargné justement quel
cadre vous vous préconisez avec votre le
parti de l'espoir pour le développement
national
le problème smcd mettre la balle à terre
revoir le cadre légal prévenir sur la
concession éclaircir le débat sur la
constitution à partir de là nous pouvons
aller vers le renforcement
institutionnel voir comment cette fois
ci nous pouvons marcher sur nos pieds
parce qu'en 2010 nous avons notifié sans
être entendus nous avons dit de
commencer à construire les bases de
l'état mais tout le monde voulait aller
aux élections et le président qui a été
lui était plus préoccupé par les
questions politiques t des questions de
développement est aujourd'hui il
faudrait remettre la balle à terre
s'asseoir réfléchir discuter de la
question est lié à la prostitution
discuter de la crédibilité des
institutions est allé sur des banquiers
on voit aujourd'hui les institutions
selon vous en guinée ne sont pas
crédibles
les institutions ne sont pas crédibles
parce que les décisions prises par les
institutions sont carrément un du parent
réduite par le pouvoir en place et
aujourd'hui dans leur nouvelle
constitution c'est le président de la
république qui doit désigner celui qui
va présider et nos institutions
républicaines institutions
constitutionnelles bien sûr et avant
c'était des pairs réunis désigné par
plusieurs portes qui devrait se réunir
pour désigner le président donc tout
cela montre combien de fois le régime
s'est durcie davantage et se replient de
plus en plus sur la dictature pure donc
aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez pas compter
sur un président de l'institution pour
faire valoir ce qui se doit
parce que tout simplement locale du
président de la cour constitutionnelle a
été un avertissement portée et si vous
rêvez
et au niveau de la justice l'expérience
aussi est là en 1h15 tous ceux qui de
2013 d'abord tous ceux qui ont dit le
droit
dans le processus électoral ont été
mutés dans les sous préfectures et des
deux villes de l'intérêt d'un côté pour
dire que quand vous dites le droit
qu'ils ne soient pas favorables au
pouvoir en place
vous allez vous retrouver dans une
situation administrative des acteurs
donc sur cette condition je ne pense pas
qu'un faible du système aujourd'hui
puisque ses preuves alors d'içi là tant
il faut mettre le système a appelé à
reconstruire des véritables repli nous
permettant d'avoir des sensations crédit
merci beaucoup marais de 6 et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chargé des relations
extérieures du pe.dn c'est le parti de
l'espoir pour le développement national
uni